j'ai l'impression qu'en france si jamais
on s'appelle à ça ne suffit pas c'est
clair que les portes de l'entreprise en
général pas pour toutes les entreprises
en général elles sont plus durs à ouvrir
arabes noirs asiatiques
l'origine ethnique est encore
aujourd'hui un frein dans la quête d'un
emploi
la discrimination à l embauche c'est un
refrain qui se répète depuis les années
et ce malgré les mesures pour l'enrayer
aggravée par des mesures de
discrimination qui n'ont rien à voir
avec les besoins objectifs de l'économie
le chômage total ou périodiques la
stabilité de l'emploi sont les soeurs
normal de livry algérien dans les années
60 et 70
la question est médiatisée avec les
vagues d'immigration algérienne la télé
montre les offres d'emploi discriminante
nationalité française exigé nationalités
européennes depuis 1972
la loi punit les actes discriminant dont
le refus d'embauché et pourtant j'avais
en moins de huit mois que cherche du
travail j'entreprends plusieurs fois
j'ai téléphoné dans une place alors par
téléphone la veille de présenter ce
moment que je me présente pour sortir
les papiers dans les années 90 le
problème passe des immigrés aux enfants
d'immigrés de nationalité française
malgré la loi la discrimination à paris
sur certaines annonces en trois lettres
bbr pour bleu blanc rouge
des associations comme sos racisme
dénonce cette injustice les missions
locales aident les concernés à trouver
du travail
et pourtant j'étais aussi une demande
dans un grand magasin pour être
caissière en m'a dit n'en comprenaient
pas de noirs à la caisse mais on avait
notre place pour moi c'était le ménage
la loi va plus loin en 1994 le refus
d'embauché clairement mentionnée dans
les textes en 1999 des commissions
départementales ont pour mission de
déceler les cas et pourtant
porter plainte juste parce qu'on la lui
au téléphone c'est notre parole contre
la sienne
et aujourd'hui on sait bien que ça
suffit pas ou auprès des tribunaux dans
les années 2000 d'autres solutions sont
à l'étude mais pas appliquer la
discrimination positive avec des quotas
d'embauché de personnes issues de la
diversité ou le cv anonyme pour que
seules les compétences soient prises en
compte pour autant me pose la question
si je voulais si ça me dérangeait pas
changé de prénom est et si par exemple
on m'appelait robert est ce que ça
posait problème depuis des années 2000
la méthode du testing tente de prouver
le délit de faciès deux candidats au cv
similaire l'heure avec un nom maghrébins
l'autre à consonance française alors que
cette méthode permettait de démontrer la
discrimination
elle sert désormais d'indicateurs en
elle montrait qu'un cv maghrébins
recevait va % de réponses en moins qu'un
concurrent franco français nous sommes
au regret de vous informer que nous ne
vous pas ce jour de postes ouverts
justement le profil
mon patron